When you're passionate about something, it comes through in your work.
And it propels your life forward in ways that you can't even imagine.
And when you choose to live by your passions, it inspires the people around you too as well.
As Marianne Williamson said,...
..."As we let our own light shine,...
...we unconsciously give others permission to do the same."
Now, imagine a life where everyone had the courage to find and follow their joy.
But what if you don't know what your true passion is?
Maybe it's something less tactile like putting a smile on people's faces.
Think of how you can combine that with something you love to do...
...and see where that gets you.
Honestly, the thing that really gets me going is making other people happy.
And here I am, sculpting tiny whimsical creatures...
...for the sole purpose of making people smile.
As soon as I chose to channel my passion and energy into both of my passions,...
...my life took off.
Now I know I am lucky.
The right people saw my work at the right time and they took to it.
But if I had never started doing what I loved in the first place,...
...there wouldn't have been any work for them to see.
No one is gonna pick you out of a crowd and say, "You there!"
"Somewhere in there, you have something we love."
Show them.
Find the courage to follow your joy.
Share it with the world and watch your life unfold.
Don't just be happy, do happy.